[Música]
ya lo decíamos y hoy vamos a Chile aquí
en directo Ah porque Pese a que el
gobierno de Gabriel borich llegó a un
acuerdo con parte de Los camioneros que
protestan en el país dos organizaciones
mantienen la huelga que ya cumple 8 días
consecutivos los involucrados aseguran
que en el pacto con El Ejecutivo no se
estipula una disminución en los precios
de los combustibles conectamos con
Patricia lunallas corresponsal de France
24 en Santiago Patricia qué es lo que
dice el acuerdo con el gobierno porque
una parte de los manifestantes sí
decidió levantar el paro pero la otra
argumenta que no hay bajada de Los
costos del combustible
Así es muy confusos los mensajes pero ya
que han supuesto una ruptura entre los
distintos sectores del gremio como
habían señalabas una parte de ellos sí
aceptaron las negociaciones del gobierno
pero en los últimos minutos los dos
sectores la confederación de
transportistas del norte y del Sur que
eran aquellos que Se mantenían este paro
parcial en el día de hoy octavo día
consecutivo han señalado que habrían
alcanzado un acuerdo que iban a firmar
en los próximos minutos con la
confederación de producción que había
mediado en este conflicto y con el
gobierno y pues sería muy probable que
los próximos minutos se anuncie un final
del paro y que hayan aceptado estas
condiciones del gobierno que estabilizan
el precio del diésel en un máximo de 0,1
céntimos de dólar en durante un periodo
de 21 días de esta forma se estaría
llegando
el fin de este paro de camioneros bueno
y cuáles están siendo los efectos de
esta huelga que sectores son los que se
están viendo más afectados
son muchos los sectores afectados en el
fantasma de esa abastecimiento planea
sobre chiles desde hace varios días
debido a la naturaleza angosta del país
que hace que mucho del transporte el 95%
de los bienes se transportan por
carretera no solo alimentación sino
también material de la construcción
maquinarias gasoil y otro afectado
especialmente al sector de agrícola de
la fruta que comienza su temporada
especialmente la exportación de cerezas
evaluaban en 500 millones de dólares
semanales las pérdidas y el paro
continuaba también a otros sectores como
el sector forestal a la carne y también
al precio y el bolsillo de los chilenos
que veían como subían al haber una mayor
escasez sobre todo las hortalizas al ir
a comprar en un contexto de fuerte
inflación esto terminaría en las
próximas horas pero amenazaba al
gobierno con ponerlo en una situación
bastante difícil debido al alza de los
precios que se vive en el país